if you want your business to grow you
have to spend dedicated time every day
that's focused just on the growth of
your business I call it CEO time I
recommend doing it first thing in the
morning and not just being a reactive
business to the fires that happen around
you but making sure you have time every
day that's focused on the big picture
goals of growing your company hi I'm
Evan Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help so today
imagine a question from one of my
readers Yvonne who wrote insane I always
enjoy reading what you write and viewing
the videos you do Thank You Yvonne I
would enjoy knowing more about taking
CEO time first thing in the morning what
does it look like what is involved so
thanks for the question for me CEO time
is things that are new projects they're
going to help me grow my business so
it's not answering email it's not doing
admin task it's not doing the stuff that
i already had planned to do that day
it's bigger picture stuff that's going
to lead to new business coming in from
my company not all the works out you try
some things and they fail but you have
to try you've got to make sure that
every day you're spending time doing
things that will help you grow your
business for most people is easier to do
it first thing in the morning before you
open your email before you check your
voicemail you spend your dedicated time
for me I do it an hour and a half chunks
because that's the easiest time to do it
once you open your email and start
getting on the phone off when your day
will explode on you and you wonder what
happened to your day right you look up
it's five o'clock already or it's eight
o'clock or it's ten o'clock at night and
you're still working so the best time to
do it is in the morning before you look
at anything else spend time on growing
your business otherwise you're just
going to be doing the day-to-day stuff
and putting out fires with no focused
effort on making this business better
than it can be for me it's always new
projects so as an example making these
videos was part of my CEO time for a
while it was a new experiment with
videos work would I enjoy it with the
fans enjoy would it help grow my
business I didn't know so I spent time
in the morning doing videos researching
the camera is testing out the different
gear seeing what would work
I put some videos up on YouTube and
people like them thank you and I like
the two I love answering the questions
it's part of my one of my favorite times
of the week is when i get to do my
videos for you guys and so i had to make
that part of my business so i took it
out of my CEO time and put it as part of
my wednesdays so now every wednesday I
come in I look at my questions I start
doing videos and then they have new CEO
projects so the idea behind the CEO
projects are new tasks that you're
trying to use to grow your business you
see if they work if they work you have
to decide if it's going to be you doing
it or ideal you can give it off to
somebody else to help you with for the
videos I think it has to be me on camera
my people are asking me a question I
like they respond personally but I don't
do all the video editing I have somebody
who that's his job he does all the video
editing for my videos so i can outsource
that part of it and then i work on new
CEO projects but the most important
thing is that you take dedicated time
you carve that out like the most
important meeting every day so that
there's always something new that's
growing in your business otherwise
you're not going to go out the treadmill
you're going to stay stuck where you are
you're not going to see any growth with
your company and you no wonder why are
you working so many hours so hard and
not seeing any growth if you want growth
you have to spend time on growth you
have to want it and you gotta dedicate
the time to it I hope that helps those
of you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below always
makes me want to do more videos for you
and if you have a question about this
video or a question for your own
business I love to help Aaron surfer you
form leave it in the comments below so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode